bonsoir alors ce soir je vous propose de
prendre l'apéro enfin je le faire pour
vous d'abord ceux ci ceci est un criquet
j'ai même un très bon criquets alors ce
que je viens de faire
le fait de manger un insecte ça
s'appelle l'entomophagie 1 vient du grec
ans thomas l'insecte falgos manger
l'entomophagie aujourd'hui on trouve sur
à peu près toute la surface de la terre
sauf dans deux endroits du globe
l'amérique du nord et l'europe
occidentale
alors pourquoi est ce que ces endroits
là on mange pas d'insectes la fao
la food and agriculture organization
s'est posé cette question dans un
rapport de 2009
elle pointe au point qui est assez
important qui à dire vous pays
industrialisés qu'ils maîtrisaient
quasiment toutes les ressources qui sont
aujourd'hui maîtrisable pourquoi ne pas
vous êtes penché sur cette matière
première qu'est l'insecte pourquoi ne
pas en manger alors qu'on peut faire
plein de choses avec très bonne question
savez vous que vous aujourd'hui vous
français tous dans cette salle vous
mangez déjà environ 300 grammes
d'insectes par an vous ne croyez pas et
pourtant vous mangez de la compote vous
manger du pain de la farine dans tous
ces ingrédients vous allez trouver des
insectes broyer concassé certes mais des
insectes quand même alors la question
qu'on va se poser c'est comment passer
de cet aspect caché à une vraie
consommation d'insectes et bat pour ce
faire je vous raconter une histoire
l'histoire par un chef
c'est très bon mais c'est un peu c'est
que pour ça que ça se prend l'apéro ça
ce point qu'une petite bière et
justement je vais vous raconter une
histoire qui a commencé autour d'un
verre de bière
l'histoire de jimmy nice jimmy nice est
une société qu'on a créé il ya deux ans
avec mon associé clément scellier et on
était tous les deux 1 vendredi soir en
sortant des études lui était en école de
commerce
ben ali et sa gallas c'est pas grave moi
je sortais de la fac de droit et on se
retrouve devant la télé à la télé qu'est
ce qu'on a
koh lanta arrive cette épreuve qu'on
connaît tous où ils sont obligés de
manger les choses peu ragoûtante et là
on tombe sur un énorme vers blancs qui
s'ils arrivent à le manger leur
permettra d'avoir ensuite la
tranquillité pour d'autres épreuves
alors on voit les candidats grimacer le
présentateur presque horrifié par le
fait de déguster cet insecte et nous
bêtement avec les mots on rigole et on
se dit mais on veut essayer ça a l'air
super donc qu'est ce qu'on fait on se
renseigne sur internet et on commande
des insectes qui viennent de thaïlande
ils mettront deux semaines arrivée en
france nous mettra deux semaines de plus
au vrai paquet mais on va finir par
dégoûter et qu'on trouvait les gouttes
et on va être très très déçu c'est pas
gluant c'est pas grouillant ça fait pas
peur du tout et c'est déshydraté ça
croque sous la dent et on a eu un peu ce
qu'on pourrait appeler une révélation
on s'est dit c'est dingue cette matière
il faut absolument qu'on en fasse
quelque chose qu'on propose des produits
parce qu'on était persuadé qu'ils
avaient déjà des produits qui existait
avant dans le rang c'était d'y envoyer
un peu petit à l'époque on va créer un
petit site internet et les meilleurs
produits qu'on va trouver on les vendra
dessus donc on a commencéà benchmark et
tout ce qu'on pouvait trouver sur la
planète en thaïlande au canada en
amérique et finalement coûté beaucoup de
choses et il n'y a jamais rien qui nous
a plu qui où l'on s'est dit voilà ça
c'est un super produit ça va être notre
best-seller
on va pouvoir le vendre tout seul alors
on a pivoté un peu notre projet et en
acheter ce qu'on va appeler de la
matière première des insectes juste
déshydraté on a commencé à faire la
cuisine nous mêmes alors on a essayé
beaucoup de choses dès qu'il y des
cupcakes des gaspachos
alors petits conseils sur je vais
utiliser une matière déshydraté la
mettais pas dans un liquide ça ne marche
pas enfin on a fait beaucoup de choses
et à chaque fois qu'on faisait des tests
on invite à tous nos amis pour qu'eux
aussi moche de l'insecte avec nous nous
donner un feedback et premiers feedbacks
qu'on a eut un soir c'est waouh c'est
vachement sympa pourquoi est ce que vous
mettez pas quelques épices dessus pour
l'assaisonner pour que ça soit ou tout
simplement un biscuit la paix
très bonne idée on a arrêté la cuisine
et là nos gâteaux d'insectes et on s'est
concentré sur assaisonner d'insectes
alors pourquoi est ce que finalement on
a choisi dans sept matières premières et
tout ce qu'on pouvait faire de prendre
le parti de faire un produit apéritif là
parce que l'apéro ça avant tout un
moment de partage
c'est un moment où on est très souvent
entre amis ou en famille et on est prêt
à échanger souvent l'alcool aide mais on
est prêt à échanger et quand vous êtes
devant un produit que vous ne connaissez
pas qui vous fait peur parce que c'est
normal quand on ne connaît pas quelque
chose toujours une appréhension
c'est un produit qui a beaucoup de
barrières je pense que parmi vous peut
on déjà manger des insectes nous on va
en discuter aujourd'hui pour passer ces
barrières et bien le plus simple c'est
de se dire tiens finalement c'est vrai
que si mon copain ma copine ma mère mon
père en mange je peux le faire aussi et
surtout casser ces barrières un sexe est
bon il faut arrêter de le voir comme
l'insecte la matière qui va
révolutionner les années 2050 qui va
tous nous sauver mais tout simplement
comme un produit alimentaire comme de la
viande comme du poulet comme plein
d'autres choses
alors j me lisent on a ensuite continué
développer notre projet aujourd'hui on
est une société tout petit une start up
mais quand même avec déjà cinq salariés
qui continuent d'avancer doucement
et pourtant on se pose toujours autant
de questions nous français et nous plus
en général c'est jimmy ni sur comment
vous faire manger des insectes
alors première question pourquoi
pourquoi manger des insectes
parce que ce sont des produits qui sont
très intéressants c'est rempli de
vitamine c rempli de protéines ça tout
le monde en a entendu parler et c'est
plein d'oméga 3 et 6 mais pas que pas
cueilli un aspect très important quand
on consomme un produit c'est de savoir
l'impact qui va avoir sur notre milieu
aujourd'hui l'insecte c'est un élevage
qui peut être fait très simplement dans
un événement comme celui-ci on peut rire
élevé plusieurs tonnes d'insectes ce
sont des bacs qu'on empile dans lequel
ils vont être élevé en deux trois
semaines
si on compare à d'autres modes
d'agriculture prenons par exemple une
vache ce que vous imaginez qu'une vache
aujourd'hui sur scène va pouvoir
s'épanouir et se développer absolument
pas pourtant mes 3 4 tonnes d'insectes
si elles ont juste besoin d'un endroit
qui soit confient les clos et dans
lequel on puisse les élever avec une
certaine chaleur la vache pour arriver à
maturation ça va être entre plusieurs
mois plusieurs années selon ce qu'on
veut obtenir le criquet au bout de trois
semaines il est prêt à être dégusté
trois semaines donc c'est une matière
qui déjà sur le plan purement écologique
est très intéressante parce que
continuant sur la vache lavage pour la
nourrir et qu'elles grossissent
il va lui falloir donner 10 kg de
nourriture pour qu'on ait un kilo de
vaches au final près de consommer le
criquet avec dix kilos de nourriture
vous avez 9 kg de criquets donc je sais
pas si vous vous rendez compte de
l'impact déjà écologique que ça peut
avoir ensuite sur un plan purement
économique
aujourd'hui quand on élève des animaux
on a besoin d'une grande surface à 9h
elle a besoin de courir dans les près de
morges et c'est le vers de farine par
exemple qui est un autre insecte a
besoin juste d'être avec 3 4 millions
ses congénères autour de lui donc dans
un bac il heureux et va se développer
vite le criquet un petit terrarium avec
quelques-uns de ses congénères il sera
heureux aussi
donc l'intérêt de cette matière première
sur un plan purement écologique sait
déjà qu'on utilise 80 % des espaces en
moins pour avoir la même culture et un
apport en protéines
encore plus intéressant bon et alors
allons encore plus loin aujourd'hui sur
mangent du boeuf on va en effet avoir un
apport en protéines qui va être
important sur mange du criquet on va
également avoir la preuve qu'un apport
en protéines important mais pas que si
on compare ces deux protéines la
protéine de criquets plus facilement
assimilable par le corps humain
c'est pourquoi j'en sais absolument rien
mais ce qui est évident c'est que notre
corps préfère ce type de protéines alors
ça nous permet de voir déjà un petit peu
mieux sur le plan de l'insecte quel est
son intérêt pour nous mais on peut se
poser une vraie question vous ai je
pense vous lisez sûrement les médias
vous écouter la radio vous regardez la
télé est très souvent vous dis 2050
on va tous mangé de l'insecte vous y
croyez moi non plus je pense
qu'aujourd'hui l'insecte c'est surtout
une vraie alternative un moyen de lutter
contre la malnutrition de lutter contre
la famine mais surtout c'est une source
de protéine alternative qu'on a sous les
yeux et qui aujourd'hui très très mal
utilisé alors oui et encore des soucis
et utiliser de l'insecte en masse parce
que si c'est une si bonne idée pourquoi
est-ce que carrefour n'en vend pas par
kilo ou auchan où je sais pas et bien
pour une raison très simple
l'industrialisation aujourd'hui est
naissante la vache on l'élève depuis la
nuit des temps
le criquet depuis finalement pas si
longtemps que ça donc on a encore de
gros progrès à faire sur
l'industrialisation sur l'utilisation
des process des machines pour arriver à
ces produits là mais ce qui est
intéressant de voir c'est qu'aujourd'hui
l'insecte tendance en condensant manche
sinon je serais pas là aujourd'hui on
commence à se dire oui ça peut être une
bonne idée il faut pousser cette idée
dans le bon sens et pour la pousser dans
le bon sens c'est très simple il faut
accompagner son développement
alors je vais vous parler cette fois ci
beaucoup de façon beaucoup plus business
on va regarder ce qui se passe en france
on va regarder le taux de création de
sociétés qui sont ciblés sur l'insecte
depuis deux ans on a à peu près 20
nouvelles sociétés qui sont créés sur
l'insecte
c'est ridicule c'est tout petit pourtant
il ya un vrai marché qu'un train de se
développer
si on regarde en europe on a des pays
qui sont leaders et pays-bas la belgique
ou le marché commence à vraiment
décoller où il ya de plus en plus
d'entreprises qui se crée d'emplois qui
se créent et par les temps difficiles
qui sont les nôtres c'est une bonne
chose si on regarde ce nouveau voisin
américain trente marques se sont créés
en seulement un an et demi 30 marques
essaient des marques qui font de plus en
plus parler d'elle
on a par exemple des produits aussi
différents que des chips à base de
farine d'insectes que des bars qui
permettrait de peut-être lutter contre
la malnutrition dans certaines parties
du globe et ce qui est intéressant de
voir surtout à travers ce taux de
création de marque c'est qu'il ya une
idée globale qui émergent c'est le fait
que oui l'insecte peut être utilisé à
d'autres fins que juste te dire que
c'est un truc qui rendent qui est par
terre qui fait peur c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut vraiment manger c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut apprécier
alors oui ça va prendre du temps parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça fait peur c'est pour
ça que je ne vous dirai pas que
l'insecte va tous nous sauver
et c'est quelque chose qu'on peut voir
comme une solution pour le futur qui
pourrait nous aider nous accompagner
notre développement
alors ce qui est intéressant de voir sur
l'insecte c'est qu'aujourd'hui malgré
toutes les bonnes choses que je viens de
vous dire quand on parle d'insectes en
europe il faut savoir qu'un paradoxe qui
est très important c'est qu'il ya un
flou juridique
on va faire un petit point droit parce
que je suis moi même juriste de
formation il ya un texte européen qui
s'appelle le novel food qui date de 1997
qui prévoit tu tournes toute une
procédure de mise sur le marché pour ce
qu'on appelle les nouveaux aliments
donc ce texte à la base il a été prévu
pour les ogm tout ce qu'on ne maîtrise
pas tout ce qui est modifié bien figurez
vous que notre ami insectes par débit
assez compliqué tombe dans le joug de ce
texte
alors pour autoriser la mise sur le
marché d'insectes aujourd'hui en europe
il faut déposer des dossiers qui sont
très coûteux plus d'un million d'euros
j'imagine et pour une petite start up
lors des grands groupes comme danone
nestlé autres ont déjà saisi l'intérêt
de l'insecte mais attendent que ce soit
des petits qu'ils aillent se casser les
reins sur de tels dossiers
pour ensuite lancer leurs produits
paradoxe mais dans le même temps vous
avez des pays à part et non par exemple
le cas de la belgique qui a contrario du
courant européen cette demande de
dossier compliqué se disent banon
pourquoi pas aujourd'hui proposer une
petite liste de 10 1 sec tu es voir ce
que ça donne sur le marché
cette position-là est bénéfique mais la
position européenne aujourd'hui c'est
que l'insecte se retrouve dans un flou
juridique
si on continue sur ce texte de 97 il en
sort par une petite porte qui prévoit en
effet que les animaux entier n'en font
pas partie et on se retrouve avec un
insecte qui n'appartient à aucun régime
il n'est pas dans le régime de
l'alimentaire commun c'est à dire qu'il
est pas soumis à des règles
il n'est pas non plus dans un régime
spécifique alors comment on veut faire
nous quand on veut développer ce produit
eh ben on est dans le flou total alors
on essaye de trouver des méthodes de
faire du lobbying mais c'est très
compliqué donc ce qu'il faut savoir
aujourd'hui c'est que le paradoxe c'est
au tour de l'insecte intéressant oui
la société évolue plus vite que les lois
c'est comme ça et aujourd'hui ce que ce
dont a besoin un sexe c'est qu'on l'aide
à se développer à trouver on va dire un
véritable terrain juridique où il
pourrait s'épanouir il faudrait leur
rentrée on va dire dans le sens que le
commun d'alimentaire pour que votre
insectes comme vos pâtes et le même
système de fabrication de traçabilité de
l'eau car aujourd'hui et c'est ça qui
est le paradoxe quand on fait de
l'insecte ya personne pour venir nous
contrôler pourquoi parce qu'on estime
que vu qu'on appartient à une catégorie
juridique d'aliments qu'on fait quelque
chose de nouveau qu'on avance conquise
moving forward et ben y'a personne qui
veut bien voir ce qu'on fait parce qu'on
n'est pas dans l'est dans les cases
voilà on n'est pas une tomate on n'est
pas un morceau de boeuf alors on sait
pas comment contrôler et c'est pourtant
est de plus en plus de tests qui sont
mis en place autour de ça et on ne
contrôle pas alors ce paradoxe et un
souci mais rassurez vous moi ça me fait
peur aujourd'hui parce que ça concerne
directement de l'entreprise je suis sûr
que d'ici deux ans ça sera réglé mais
j'essaye de vous a attirée sur le fait
que pour avancer très souvent malgré le
fait qu'on ait tout ce qu'il faut un
produit génial des bonnes idées ça prend
du temps car les mentalités même si
elles sont pas prêtes ce qui est encore
plus réticents c'est le système
juridique dans lequel on est alors
peut-être et peut-être que dans quelques
années quand on regardera koh lanta
j'espère que ce sera toujours là dans
quelques années on dira bravo
il a réussi son épreuve d'immunité il en
a chié mais il a bien mérité son petit
criquet
merci à vous